une offensive qui intervient alors
qu'une délégation talibane est
actuellement à moscou la russie
s'inquiète d'une escalade des tensions
au delà des frontières de l'afghanistan
pour en parler on retrouve en direct de
moscou notre correspondante vera goffman
bonjour on le disait une délégation du
bureau politique des talibans est
actuellement à moscou ils ont tenu une
conférence de presse ce matin que
faut-il en retenir mon jeu de ramener
les talibans grand disque les
territoires de l'afghanistan ne sera
plus jamais utilisée par un pays tiers
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le chercheur
boudine de l'avare membre de l'équipe de
négociation de l'émirat islamique
d'afghanistan lors de sa visite à moscou
il a également promis que les talibans
ne saisiront pas des centres régionaux
par la force et ne mèneront pas
d'activités militaires hostiles show
propose d'écouter la cac et mangue
nous garantissons que notre territoire
ne sera plus jamais utilisée par un pays
tiers nous voulons avertir tout le monde
que nous prendrons toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour que le mouvement de
l'état islamique ne perd jamais sur le
territoire afghan et que notre pays ne
soit pas utilisé contre eux des pays
voisins encontre des pays amis nous
affirmons que la production de drogue
est un problème mondial
nous assurons que nous prendrons des
mesures pour lutter contre la production
de drogue et voulons me garantir à la
communauté mondiale comme la barre -
j'ai d'ailleurs nous ne saisiront pas
des centres régionaux par la force et
nous ne mènerons pas d'activités
militaires hostiles
les propositions que nous avons
formulées indiquent qu'il n'y aura pas
d' attaque actifs sur les centres
administratifs des provinces tous les
prisonniers des deux côtés doivent être
libérés nous devons gagner la confiance
du peuple afghan pour construire la paix
ces propositions ont été transmises à la
partie américaine et aux autorités
officielles de kaboul par monsieur
khalil zad
pour sa part in peace des mollahs les
hommes et d'alcool dans le sang
la délégation a également expliqué la
raison de son arrivée à moscou
écoutez quand la russie est un pays
important dans la région de
l'afghanistan
il ya eu des développements récents et
nous considérons qu'il est nécessaire de
parler avec eux de la situation récente
en afghanistan qu'ils nous entendent
pour discuter des diverses inquiétudes
et aussi pour leur donner des
explications sur ce qui s'est passé dans
le pays
so to give them explanation à badaling
accompli selon le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov la
russie suit de près ce qui se passe en
afghanistan où la situation tend à cdtt
détériorer rapidement notamment dans le
cadre du retrait hâtif des forces
américaines qui n'ont pas réussi à
obtenir des résultats tangibles en
matière de stabilisation de la situation
en afghanistan après des décennies de
présence dans ce pays
verhaeghe hoffman en direct de moscou
merci pour toutes ces précisions